[Music]
well hello everybody
hey my name is Vitaly namer and I began
master in residence at the same - it's
just them and welcome to our viewers
both live and online and today our
lesson is going to be the viewers choice
which we are going to be focusing on
analyzing fans games so let's let's see
some of the games today okay so here's
the first one hopefully I'm pronouncing
it correctly but this is from Joe juice
till vollis and George's says greetings
from Greece I'm a huge fan of Yasser ban
in a YouTube channel and I enjoy the
live coverages of all the events time
done by the team so thank you very much
I play a lot of blitz games on chess
calm so the weak and low low rated
players of course so do we and this game
I felt like submitting because the
computer analysis give me a caps of 96
plus tax all right
and only one inaccuracy in the end so
almost a perfect game for him I am black
in this game the opponent in the end mr.
threat but I was better anyway and I
think the game is interesting regardless
would be happy to see if it was featured
in your videos so Julius you are lucky
because you were the chosen one today
okay it's a George yeah so his name is
George alright so greetings from some
Greece hey by the way I'm a huge fan of
Greek food yummy the feeling their food
is just just amazing
okay so let's see yes so that's like
let's look at the game I'm gonna going
to flip the board so I urge is a
defender of the Sicilian defense as you
can see she plays c5 and now is six all
very good
so transposing kind of to the my
transpose of the con defense or Paulsen
with e6 I actually played with black as
well a little bit less popular then then
openings like the dragon or or the night
off but playable very good move and now
and usually white plays this move d4 so
this is the main line in most most of
the open Sicilian variations but instead
why I decided to play this move Bishop
to e2 so a little bit more a little bit
more passive and move Bishop to e2 but
still it still allows Y to play d4 in
the future okay so here George played
Knight to f6 will move we develop our
pieces right so the second opening
principle now just a small comment I
will
I would personally prefer Knight go into
c6 first just because it's more natural
so usually what black is developing the
b8 Knight first because it cannot get
attacked
now after Knight to f6 this knight on f6
can be attacked by this move e5
now it's not the end of the world of
course because the night can just jump
to five and we can transpose to many
openings for example it can't and
supposed to the a lopunny the c3 and for
example if 96 then d4 and so on and so
on so yeah so that so the 96 is of is a
fine move but it allows 'if I've at the
same time but why the size just to play
this move Knight c3 so so far so good
looks like white is developing his
pieces not a lot of action on the board
and now 96 very well and here white
played this move h3 so other guys think
about that our views our fans at home
exactly so what does that move do
usually the h3 pawn is doing two things
as two jobs number one we call it a
window so the King won't be made on the
back rank so it opens up a route for the
King to escape now in this case first of
all white didn't even castle so that's
pretty much premature the second goal of
h3 is sometimes to disallow any pins for
example this Bishop sometimes come to g4
and pinning pinning tonight but in our
case really the bishop cannot come to g4
but also White has a defense already
against the pin so really the h3 porn
was was not so necessary
it doesn't really harm white but we know
that especially in the opening time is
very valuable
right and so HD just loses some time
instead again probably a move like like
d4 or castle would be much more natural
okay so why play this move h3 so how
should black respond let's think for for
a few seconds now just as a reminder if
why could have played d4 and black would
capture a knight would capture on before
usually in those kind of situations
black and play other d6 a6 Queen c7
sometimes even Bishop to b4 immediately
but well really the the golden chairs is
realizing the mistake of your opponent
and seizing that mistake so in this game
George you have seized the moment and
you played d5 very good job George the
first principle of the opening
controlling the center if and if the
opponent allows us to do it then why not
okay so pawn takes 25 now Georgia took
with the night I was wondering he could
also take the pawn as well both moves
are good I think that taking with a pawn
also allows your bishop to come out so I
would prefer to take the pawn but it's a
medal of taste in this case so Knight
takes d5 Castle
now Bishop e7 very good Bishop to b5
white plate hmm okay so it looks like
white realized that he put the bishop on
not such a good square oniy to passive
passive square and now he activates the
bishop with Bishop to b5 an interesting
moment actually in the game because at
first we see that okay so the knight is
pinned by the bishop but he's defended
right so it's not a big threat
so usually beginning chess players would
immediately Castle this is the most
logical move in the position Castle but
White has a hidden threat he would
actually take the knight although we
know that the bishops are slightly
better than the Knights and after the
pawn takes on b6 white can play a rook
to e1 and the game becomes very very
positional so why buy white giving up
his bishop for the night he made those
weaknesses for black those double pawns
now how should white proceed for example
if black plays Ruby 8 just for example
so think about how should how should I
proceed in such positions now the first
thing that would come into your mind is
probably pawn to d4 right just seizing
the center now this move is a good move
because it is developing pieces but you
are also allowing your opponent to get
rid of his weaknesses so there will be
no more advantage so usually in such
positions actually white refrains from
playing pawn to d4 but he will probably
play pawn to d3 and that is to put the
pawns on white squares in this case I
will probably have to move the knight
first so if I because if I played Italy
immediately then what the knight can
take on c3 but the idea is to get some
kind of position like this and b3 and
then put some extra pressure on this
pawn on c5 okay it's very annoying for
black to play kind of position because
the bishop on e7 has to keep his defense
on c5 and this Bishop on c8 is just
turned off so let's go back to the game
so why just played this move Bishop to
b5 so how do we defend well George found
the most obvious solution and this is
Bishop 37 so good job now I understand
why he got a good score so far so good
Knight takes on d5 pawn takes rook to e1
castle and finally white plate to d4 now
the position here is still pretty equal
symmetrical pawn structure to bishop
sedan and a knight like the side to take
and here white took on c6
now why is that why could not white take
on d4
because of a simple combination right so
always we look for threats checks and
captures all the action moves so let's
see what happens if black takes the
night
now if Y takes the the night obviously
he's losing a piece that's a good for us
in this case a white will have to take
on this seven and hope the black would
retake and Queen takes on d4 this
position looks pretty good for white
because white can now get his attack on
the isolated point but we forgot a very
important important principle an
intermediate move okay they intervenes
oh so this is the move in between moves
so instead of Queen taking on d7 Knight
can take on c2 excellent
and after Queen tastes and queen takes
on d7 in this case black would stay with
a pawn up so why did the correct choice
see it took the knight first now the
question is with which piece to take the
bishop think about at home would you
take with the bishop or with the pawn
now in both K both cases look good for
example if you take with the bishop then
looks like you activated your bishop
maybe the Queen now is a little bit more
active but the problem is is really the
bishop is not so active he's really
stuck upon this point and after the nine
takes on d4 we are stuck with this
isolated pawn now we do have two bishops
but we are stuck with the isolated pawn
so preferably black should have Jojo
sort of taking with the pawn because in
this case that say Knight takes d4 now
you can actually play even c5 and start
pushing the pawns and if Knight f3
Bishop a5
beautiful pair of Bishops so
maybe maybe this was the tax maybe this
was the inaccurate move so Georgia took
her the bishop Knight takes on d4 Bishop
going to c5 very well activating the
bishop and c3 so actually why does
playing pretty good up until this point
why chose not to take the knight on c6
because you realize that the knight
might impose more danger for for blacks
position he's attacking the the pinch
off you can always take the bishop you
can sometimes jump to f5 to create some
extra threats on the King side so in
this case by the way the best blockading
piece is the night so c3 like White
Queen f6 very well developing the Queen
Bishop to e3 okay rook F to e8
go into g4 excellent
rook to e8 x of the e4
now black George you played Bishop to d6
I would actually prefer just to finish
up my developer I like all of my pieces
to be developed that's my that's one
number one rule for my students don't
attack and once all the before all the
all your pieces are developed in this
case black does have lots and lots of of
pressure especially on the e-file not so
easy for white to play now Bishop d6 is
probably a good move because it gets a
threat but this threat we call a simple
threat you are just typing something and
the opponent is going to move away
instead you would like to make hidden
threats like rook a to e8 we don't
really want to take the bishop on e3 but
when other there is a very powerful pin
over here on the e-file so Bishop d6
here white realize that his position is
actually not so so good and decided
correctly to trying to exchange the
Queen's right so we when we are under
all this pressure and we are being
attacked we would like to transpose to
the endgame hopefully exchanging the
Queen's George played correctly he
refused they played Queen to g6
so still out of pleasure ever Black has
so what to do here wood wood white what
would you do here with wife he white
actually made he's a big mistake not so
easy to spot the mistake that it is a
mistake but think about it as a
principles I was just telling you about
how the harmony of the of the pieces
okay so what would you do here in this
position with white now if you said
let's develop our last piece which is
rook a to d1 you're correct
yeah so now we want to put the rope
behind the knight so once an eye jumps
maybe takes the bishop one day the d5
point is going to get attacked another
way would be trying to create your own
battery on the OD file so cantle battery
gonna be two major forces fighting on
the e-file but
white played Knight to f5 now the idea
of neither five is actually not so bad
because white is again trying to
exchange some extra pieces like the
bishop on d4 and d6
once the bishop on d6 is going to be
exchanged and black and white who put
his Bishop on d4 then although we have
an opposite color Bishop position with
rooks and Queens although it looks like
a draw but actually white has a lot a
lot of advantage but 9f5 was actually a
critical mistake in the game so try to
think in this position how would you
punish white for this move okay so I had
a few options some people say the rook
takes Bishop sorry people say d4
interesting interesting ideas so let's
discuss that so as we know in the in the
Czech in chess we have what we call a
thinking process so number one what I do
after my opponent makes a move like
Knight to f5 is that I have to ask
myself why didn't he make this move
what's his threat right now we already
said that he wants to exchange your
Bishop so maybe we should move the
bishop
maybe we shouldn't know that right
yeah that's great I can't move it to c7
very nice yes if I move my bishop here
and queen takes and queen e7 nice
combination maybe I have to move my
bishop to f8 and say okay well we live
we'll let this bishop live another day
but this looks pretty passive right so
let's go next the next thinking process
is that to ask yourself what has changed
in a position so what is changing the
position where the knight was on d4 and
now he's on a fine so it allows us to
make this move T for opening up the
bishop the diagonal very dangerous
diagonal now if we take the bishop first
on e3 like it was suggested and I assume
that this also the idea so let's think
about what is the issue in this one so
Knight takes rook and if I still play d4
Knight to d5 yeah and if I try to attack
the knight even more
sec yeah so c4
yeah and looks like why this is fine
just an exchange up okay good so doesn't
work but we had to consider that it's a
action move right to chest captures next
is gonna be threats so d4 in George
found this beautiful move expose the
center so let's let's think about what
is what's going on here
now if the knight now takes on d6 then
the rooks takes the bishop on e3 not
only the rook is attacking the Queen
also the bishop is attacking the Queen
and exactly them there's a mad matron on
g2 so in the game White had to take on
default with the night but even here we
use the same combination rook takes on
e3
and the Queen took on a tree and queen
takes on g2o he didn't see them and this
mate is called the kiss of death so
George from Greece thank you for the
wonderful game and hope we hope to see
you here the same two is just stopped
coming to visit us okay
dear viewers right now we have a new
game to analyze which was played by met
manly against the can and can is a very
developed member of a chess club he he
comes to all of our classes so it's a
good job did yeah that's why I called
the vacation okay so that's it so white
so can was playing black and metal
playing white let's see so Matt played
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 very tricky
this move Knight of the white does not
reveal his intentions really this
disposition can go into so many openings
it can go to the Sicilian even if with
black ties c5 can go to the reti or the
English can go to the Queen's Gambit so
really black is the one who is going to
choose the the opening so Knight of 6
and the can says you know what I also
don't reveal my my plans so that's
that's the night dance
okay now g3 okay faint chattering the
pawn
great so what is the best sponsor for
black
you can do the same thing just six yeah
that's a good move yeah so g6 is is a
fine move just transposing to say
something symmetrical don't know at the
end about something symmetrical you can
play d6 yeah I think that black should
probably control the center there are
two moves is c5 mostly forces the
Sicilian players the electrically
assisted c5 in such positions but can
chose this principle move d5 very good
can you probably watch my other videos
but the opening principles very good
Bishop to g2 and now you played Knight
to c6 okay
now 96 looks like a logical move right
it looks like a kind of the four Knights
right if if white takes out his other
Knights would just with D fall on the
board looks like a very logical move to
to take out the knight on c6 and then
playing a5 but whatever but other
viewers say that actually black white
can play now d4 and this is what
happened in the game now this position
it is very strange but we don't supposed
to the kind of the Catalan Queen's
Gambit it's very strange that the knight
on c6 is is misplaced although it's in
the center is developed but in the in
the end white is going to play c4 at
some point and we don't have the support
of the pawn on c6
very very strange phenomenon but yeah so
how should we play here not 96 yeah so
here there is the basically a few moves
few options
the c5 I mean for example Castle and now
96 that's a complete different story and
actually here you can transpose to the
reversed Rothfeld
so if white plays d4 you take 9 takes an
e5 Knight takes c6 C pawn takes c6 and
we got the reversed Grunfeld white is
playing black and black is playing white
and that's such a bad position for black
right I mean we have the center although
you have to know a little bit about the
ideas on how to play against c4 and
stuff like that so this is option number
one option number two I actually had a
game against the teammate of mine
justice Williams when I played I think I
just played g6 so we just went to the
symmetrical position and we because it's
symmetrical it ended in a draw fine ship
one so let's look at what happens 96 not
the end of the world on at the end of
the world
d4 Bishop to g4
so Bishop g4 looks again looks like we
are developing the bishop but why I can
play that's correct
Knight to e5 would be very strong move
because we cannot take the knight pawn
takes Knight now we have some very big
issues with this pawn on d5 so suddenly
Bishop to g4 does not work so well now
why did not play 95 so how should we
have we played instead with black well
again similar we can either find chatter
this Bishop from g6 we can play just
continue employee 6 or maybe take out
the Bishop to a5 and let's say example
Castle Denny 6 doesn't look so bad at
some point we will have to move the
knight to release the simple the C pawn
Bishop g4 why decided to castle first
it's fine now can you play the Queen to
d7 you know I think that you probably
watched too many of my videos about
tactics and mating attacks but that but
I like your passion I like the fact that
you want to make him immediately a very
interesting idea unfortunately here
especially in this position white can
play Knight to e5 that's even a stronger
form and again if you take take and we
losing the d5 pawn because if 94th and
f3 but again he did not do it okay so
he's a very principled player and he he
played c4 okay so I was the idea of c4
the idea of the of c-4 is that white
wants to give up a pawn he is
sacrificing upon to get a better grip in
the center
so what if we will take the pawn on one
thing maybe we should take the pawn
I like this for me because a I'm winning
upon and bd5 was a huge headache for me
so now if he plays 95 but this is not
such a big I think I still have a
headache
but if 95 now I can take take take the
Queen
and I cannot take here 97 Bishop takes
still cannot take here let's boogie too
not sure what to put the rock b8 or D
it's still a tough position still a
tough position Robi a bishops is 6 B 6
Bishop a4
question is how do I take this one out
maybe g6 yeah can we just six still
still I don't like so much that the pawn
structure but at least we were alive
alive and kicking
so after c4 can he went all-in
Bishop h3 I like your determination you
you're playing you don't care you don't
you say nothing care what you're playing
but I'm gonna meet you I'm sticking to
my plan okay
well let's see if it worked oh now white
played night 283
Wow what is this
so night city would be probably much
much preferable so 983
okay Bishop takes g2 king 282 and they
played six okay yeah finally looks not
so bad actually right now not so bad
I would actually I was wondering if you
had some thoughts about trying to make
him on the Kings side lots of in it's
very fashionable fashionable nowadays if
you looked at the World Cup and the
single cup those moves a5 and h5 like an
onion plate yeah and now the h4 is
coming and some weakening wicking of the
King maybe even g5 that that might be
interesting and if you take my pond now
I'm not afraid of taking it with the
Queen because you don't have the knife
here anymore
the knight is out of the game so eh 510
just for you I'm gonna make another
video about h5 and a4 a5
thank you okay so II six Bishop f4 and
now a six
like like one of my coaches used to say
we were afraid of ghosts of ghosts let's
calculate this but first of all let's
say we're just going to continue without
the table just Bishop e7 now yes white
can play Knight to b5 an attack on our
pollen c7 but in this case we have a
very simple defense rook c8 right now it
it won't allow you to castle long and
checkmate him so that was probably was
the the reason why I didn't play that
but you know we have to be flexible
without plants you're still competing we
just just have to just gonna take longer
and that is that next move a six is
coming yeah you just put the night given
the boot so now the provided by the
problem with a6 is that it shatters all
our dreams of long castle when we have
such a structure with the pawns like
this in one line is the perfect
structure because there are no
weaknesses right but when we make one
move a six or b6 or c6 usually a six is
there is the best one we it gates what
we call a hook okay now white will have
a target for attack
for example maybe b4 b5 alright so
there will be no long castle probably
and why play the c5 very good move I
like this move for white because
disallowing the the exchange blocking of
your Bishop gaining space not allowing
you to take the build a Knight Bishop e7
you played 92 white realized that final
that his Knight is in a bad spot and you
castles short and white played a four
yeah so that is to play b4 and b5 well
let's see what Ken did Ken went for the
bishop nice to h5 now sometimes those
hoops are good but they are usually good
when you actually get the bishop so for
example if white would have played III
in this case I would say that night h5
is justified but in case of a for what
happened in the game is an after night
h5 white made the correct decision to
move his Bishop back rook F to e 8
yeah I think it's the correct idea
usually a rule of thumb when you
opponent attacks you on the flanks you
want to strive to explode the position
in the center so I like the idea of of
playing a5 not sure if I would start
with this move but yeah definitely looks
not so bad Duke F to e8 b for Bishop to
f8 yeah you have to move the bishop here
because if you move it here then g4
coming right he played III
okay so eating is a very tricky move
right you guys see that because now we
cannot play e5 actually can we play you
five so if it takes the pawn Knight
takes Knight takes but attacking all
nine the Queen's attacking all night but
not the RO can't take but f4 yes Andrey
for 194 yeah okay can used his
unbelievable
instincts and did not play e5 good sense
of danger just like spider-man so you
played Knight f6
good getting the knight back into the
game so in the end it's not it wasn't
such a bad maneuver because his bishop
is more passive on d2 but I'm afraid
that his pawn storm is going to be very
very fast and deadly Queen e2 oh ok so
the idea is that white wants to connect
the rocks
I like that for white but putting the
code the Queen in the front of their of
the rook not a good idea and can what
happened
you played 94 what about our plan I
remember our dreams freedom
[Laughter]
what's happened with if I way that it
doesn't work because of b5
let's see we have to well if it takes
then our position was pretty good I like
like now not so not so bad right the
only thing for us to calculate is what
if he counter-attacks would be
functional yes exactly
now let's see if it takes takes takes
who needs to take care I'd like one
structure so I guess I will take the
Queen maybe we're the pawns is fine as
well
maybe actually with the pawn is fine as
well and then next move is going to be
94 now I like this position because what
happened is that we got rid of the
Knights right so which is good for us
because they cannot attack you would be
five but also our work is much more
developed so we're here I thought that
that was your chance maybe he won't even
play before me we will just exchange
everything and in this case putting the
rocks into place sometimes defaults
coming
so can I like your plants the mating
plants the e5 players the freedom plans
but you have to stick to them yeah don't
change your plans
it's like a with investments you know I
have to just pick a stock just let this
leave it that right there don't go out
okay so Bishop f8 let's see Queen 994
you played
technically it's a good still a good
move but I played B 597 the night went
back I thought you're giving up you gave
up the e5 square so 95 okay so now we
have some some problems yeah now I feel
squeezed like like a can of tuna and now
he played also f3 now this is
interesting because after f3 looks like
a good move but it took it in the bishop
sometimes I would maybe try to play
Bishop to e1 first and Dentistry to
squeeze you more ok the mole the the
less space you have but the more pieces
you have it actually you have less less
and less space so I would play Bishop d1
so f 3
got the right decision and now f6 okay
okay so not all is lost
Knight to d3 oh now you took on d5 this
I don't really like so much because I
think that the a file is going to be
used by white more than black so
therefore that that's why I thought I
liked the fact that you kept the pawns
over there maybe maybe maybe he's going
to make a mistake and play b6 maybe it's
gonna be a lucky man like a day but so
what what are the instead of taking on
b5
yes.can is following his dreams 96 and
he fine yeah I think I think the
position will be actually not so bad for
you not so bad
yeah so this lady gave a counter play
for White Queen d7 Queen B 496 okay so
he spotted our plans and Plan F for now
I played b6 I think that b6 is a it's
kind of a controversial move I'm not I'm
not sure about this year we put a pawn
yeah it gives him c6 but also puts our
pawns on dark squares not much I'm not
sure if I would what what is the idea
what about be fived
why not if I I 5 so this was a whole
plan is it taking not maybe f5 maybe f5
not so bad because after the night moves
you are taking on 83 right
yes so II five Free Willy that's when he
jumps over and goes to the well goes to
the to the sea okay III 9a bb6 was
played c6 okay
Queen d8 so if we take the Queen aha it
takes on d7 and everything is hanging
that's not good so six six was a very
strong move yeah
so Queen d8 would you play Queen f7
instead give me yeah I so basically I
just want to keep my rooks connected to
each other if it takes I get up the file
that would with a queen because if I if
I went like you did in the game with a
queen deed then I assumed he took no I
actually didn't it played Queen to ah he
has to go with a queen back first
yeah but now he wants to take your rook
and put the other work on anyone so you
had to take finally it happened if I've
it's a miracle but I'm kind of afraid
because now yeah some some hunters came
to to this diagonal so you feel really
but the hunters are after him okay so a
five-night to be for which night
see okay I assume let's see because it's
more behind let's see if it works
eta is d4 Knight takes d5 you know I
have to get your King away because he
wants to check with you in two moves
rook a7o get spicy over here D takes III
rook takes c7 North Queen I ate well
it's actually not so stupid but what's
that why not to do it immediately you
want a to as we say charge
all right I think yeah so this is this
is just a competition who's gonna be
it's a race but Queen a8 really gave him
the edge Oh
because now you found a strong move
let's see if anybody can see that
actually naturally it's winning let's
see so Knight takes f6 was played
threatening a mate
now you did not take the knight well I
don't feel de tonight
I assume Queen f7 right right but that's
defendable
yeah Bishop e7 now we are still not out
of danger because I think maybe can if
you sacrifice that's okay but maybe you
can play f5 your position looks tough
it's very tough
okay that's at the end of the game you
played Bishop d7 you believed him that
the knight is poisoned Bishop e7 but now
he just took here yeah unfortunately
without the rock on without the support
of the rock on he ate this pollen III
becomes useless almost Queen is six are
very strong over I like that I like that
they paralyzes black Queen f8 because
you can't play clean da because of Rudy
7 rook c8 and c7 and white one well not
such a bad mood that's just to get bed
game can so very good I like the fact
that you finally pushed a five so you
did have some chances you just had ready
to move even further don't just stop at
E 5 in III to keep keep moving e 2 and
so on
alright good job which I thank you
you
[Applause]
[Music]